Candace Owens is the host of the Candace
Owens podcast she joins us tonight
Kenneth thanks so much for coming on
um how much more of Michelle Obama do
you think we'll be seeing between now
and say the January primaries of 2024.
I think you have it exactly right I
think we're going to be seeing a lot of
her and I know that we've all been
wondering who are they going to put up
as a candidate it's become very clear
the media is dumping Joe Biden right
suddenly they're able to critique hunt
in Biden's laptop they're able to look
at all of his corruption and things that
they just were unwilling to do for the
first four years of his presidency so
they're basically saying we no longer
have your back now we're saying that you
do do some bad stuff and oh maybe he's
not just forgetful sometimes maybe he is
in fact senile and we're not going to
have him fourth as a candidate it begs
the question you know which ISM are they
going to run on this is what they do you
are correct you have sexism which we I
think people grew very tired of after
Hillary Clinton we get it we all hate
women we're all misogynists according to
the left and they ran Hillary and she
didn't win when they ran Biden of course
it was racism it was everybody is a
racist it was a coveted pandemic you're
right about these emergencies what I
will say about Michelle Obama is I think
she's smarter than to run on just race
because people forget this but Obama was
smarter than to run on just race the
first time that he ran he refused to
answer those questions I think what
she's doing and the reason why she's
talking about her menopause is she's
making an Oprah appeal she's appealing
to Suburban women because that's the
people that's the group of individuals
that Biden lost right so she thinks that
she makes herself relatable to Suburban
women and she just does you know just
remembers answers basic answers like
what is your name things that Joe Biden
can't remember what are your children's
name that she can get by because she
knows that she'll have the full support
of the media behind her so I don't doubt
that they are priming her to be the
candid because I don't know who else
they have to put forth well that's it I
mean the bench is thin I mean Gavin
Newsom presiding over the worst manage
state in American history I don't think
there's really much debate about that at
this point I mean literally and then and
then Kamala camel or Carmela whatever
her name is she can't decide Harris
you know anyone who laughs at the idea
of Michelle Obama becoming President
should remember that Joe Biden is the
president
that's exactly right and that's why I
would not laugh I would not laugh at it
because she is a way stronger candidate
of course than Joe Biden who didn't even
have to go to any rallies he had he had
a bunch of cars that were honking at him
it's definitely something to consider
seriously and I don't know what the
point would be I guess just to pretend
that things are changing we know it's
just a continuation of the Clinton
Administration to the Obamas to the you
know to the Biden that's all the same
but I guess people believe that it's
actually changed if they have a
different person and they'll just be
relieved that they're not having to
fight for fight for Biden again and
pretend that he's a legitimate you know
a legitimate president and he obviously
can't even hold a decent press
conference or speak to the media
whatsoever and of course Kamala Kamala
however you say her name nobody is
taking her seriously she has that
Hillary Factor she's just unlikable you
put her in front of a camera and you
walk away and you just kind of go oh my
gosh what was that I don't like her and
I don't know why you can't really
explain what it is but there's no way
they're going to run an election with
her and I think it's very real that
Michelle Obama is going to be her
candidate I I think you're right I do
great to see you Kenneth Owens thanks so
much subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight